[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
عمليه في محطه القطارات شمال العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس والشرطه تعلن تحديد
المهاجم
تقوم بتمشي مدينه
مصادر استخباراتيه تؤكد احباط اسرائيل
لمخطه في سوريا كلف ايران ملايين
الدولارات
شرطه مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه تحقق في
طرد مشبوه ملوث باليورانيوم كان بطريقه
لشركات الايراني
عندما حطت القطارات بعد عمليه الطعن من
جهتها اعلنا الشركه القطارات الفرنسيه
عوده الحركه لطبيعتها في المحطه بعد ان
اقامه الشرطه الحواجز الامنيه
اذا مشاهدينا هذه صور مباشره من مترو
باريس من المحطه محطه قطار الشمال التي
تعرضت لاعتداء في هذا اليوم حيث اصيب سته
اشخاص كانوا في هذه المحطه الشرطه كما
ذكرنا مشاهدينا قامت بتقويم بالتطويق
المنطقه وقامت حواجز تعطر قبل ذلك حركه
القطارات طبعا في هذه المنطقه لكنها الان
بدات تعود الى طبيعتها حسب شركه القطارات
الى مشاهدينا هذه مشاهد اوليه من همم من
المحطه محطه القطارات التي تعرضت للاعتداء
هذا اليوم والشرطه الفرنسيه اعلنت انها قد
حيدت المهاجم ونقل الى المستشفى بعد
اصابته هذه الصور مباشره الان من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس بعد هذا الهجوم على محطه
قطارات الشمال كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا سته
جرحه جراء عمليه الطعن في محطه قطارات
الشمال في باريس
بدات قوه الروسيه عمليه التطهير الاراضي
بلده سوليدار شمال امريكا
في المقام الاول بالنسبه مؤكدا انه على
اتصال بقاده القوات الخاصه الشيشانيه
لمشاهدين بعدما تحولت مدينه السوليدار
الواقعه في شرق اوكرانيا والقريبه من باقي
الى اكثر النقاط سخونه على جبهه المعارك
في اوكرانيا انتشر مقطع مصور لجندي
اوكراني يناشد فيه دعما للقوات الاوكرانيه
انهم يقاتلون من اجل حريتنا ايضا
هذا هو قال السفير الروسي في واشنطن
انتولي تدريب الولايات المتحده لطواقي مع
عسكريه اوكرانيه على انظمه باتريوس
الدفاعيه الصاروخيه يؤكد الخراطه واشنطن
بحكم الامر الواقع في النزاع في اوكرانيا
واضاف السفير الروسي ان هدف الاداره
الامريكيه هو الحاقه اكبر قدر من الضرائب
روسيا في ميدان المعركه باياد الاوكرانيه
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعلنت انها
ستدرب طواقي مع عسكريه اوكرانيا في قاعده
النبي
عسكريه بين روسيا وحلف شمال كل شيء
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
في تصريحاته يعتبر ايضا ان الغربه يحاول
نحو روسيا من الخريطه السياسيه العالم على
هذه التصريحات قال متحدث باسم الكريم لان
ديميتر بيسكوف الى نيته والولايات المتحده
جزء من الصراع في اوكرانيا معتبرا اياهم
اطرافا غير مباشره وذلك بحكم مدهم
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والتقنيات والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
ابدا وزير خارجيه ارميني قرارات ميروزيان
اعتراضه على اغلاق ممرض لاتشين وهو الطريق
الوحيد الذي يربط
ارمينيا بالعالم الخارجي وجاء ذلك اثناء
محادثه مع مساعدته وزيره الخارجيه
الامريكيه للشؤون الاوروبيه
مدينا اذا تصرفات اذربيجان ومحمد اياها
مسؤوليه تراجع الوضع الانساني في المنطقه
وقالت خارجيه ارمينيه في بيان لها من
المبررات من الجانب الادريسي
لاغلاق المراه كاذبه ولا اساس لها
مشاهدينا افاده مصادر استخباراتيه ان
اسرائيل نجحت في احباط المخطط الايراني
لانشاء نظام
الايراني مستقل للدفاع الجوي من داخل
سوريا
البريطانيه ينضم الى مدير المصدر السوري
لحقوق اللي صار عمي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
سيدراني معنا في هذه النشره ما الذي قال
اليه هذا المشروع الايراني للدفاع الجوي
هل تم القضاء عليه فعلا من قبل اسرائيل
انه ما زال قيد التطوير والانشاء
نعم
خاصه في ايران وتحدثنا اكثر من مره حقيقه
الامر عندما تكون هناك ضربات اسرائيليه
على المستودعات الايرانيه او النقالات
الايرانيه بان هناك مشروع للدفاع الجوي
الايراني وحتى في وثيقه نشرناها الشهر
الفائت ونشرتها الحدث العربيه عن من اداره
الدفاع الجوي في النصاب يطلبون من اداره
التموين ان يكون هناك معدات الدفاع الجوي
الايرانيه ايرانيه لان لا يوجد تلبيه
لروسيا لهذه الدفاعات داخل الدفاعات
الجويه على المشروع على المشروعه ضرب
اجزاء من المشروع نعم ضرب ولكن المشروع لا
يزال قائم هناك محاولات حثيثه همم للعام
الفائز مرتين ضرب في اللاذقيه او عفوا في
طرطوس حقيقه امر في جبال طرطوس وايضا في
ريف دمشق الدور بهذا المشروع وقرب مصياف
او عن طريق مصياف بطرس ايضا بعد بطاريه
الدفاع الجوي او المستودعات التي كانت هي
في اطار العمل طيب اين هو الجيش السوري
وجيش النظام السوري من هذه المعادله ما
مدى همم انخراطه في التعاون مع النظام
الايراني في النصب هذه المنظومه الخطيره
يعني هناك بعض الاحيان يدرب عليها ضباط من
الدفاع الجوي ولكن هناك انتقائيه حتى ضمن
الجيش العربي السوري بين مزدوجين هناك
انتقائيا الايرانيين من يتدرب معهم هل
يثقون بكام الاعضاء الجيش العربي السوري
بين مزدوجين الايرانيين يكونون باختيار
واخبار من يريدون العمل معهم لانهم لا
يسيقون حتى بقوات النظام هم يريدون على
الاراضي السوريه شيء يختص في ايران فقط
لانهم يعتبرون ان سوريا الان او اجزاء من
السوريه باتت جزاء لولايه الفقيه الجزء
الايرانيين عندنا من نشاهد مستودعات قدره
في المطار على سبيل المثال المستودع تابع
لحزب الله وبعد تقرير سوف ينشر تقرير عن
تدمر وتقرير عن السيده زينب هناك مستعمرات
ايرانيه كامله ما بالك على الوضع العسكري
هم لا يثقون على الاطلاق بقوات النظام
ويستمرون ارتفاعات جويه خاصه
داخل الاراضي السوريه طيب ماذا نعرف عن
الخسائر ايرانيه من هذه الضربات همم
الاسرائي جعل منظومات الدفاع او منظومات
الدفاع الجوي الايرانيه بالتاكيد هناك
خسائر همم ماديه وخسائر لوجستيه لكن ماذا
عن خسائر البشريه
قبله ونتحدث عن اكثر من 60 قتيل من اشياء
ايران في الاراضي السوريه كان يعملون مع
الايرانيين في المستودعات في منظومه
الدفاع الجوي ولكن ايران اعترف بثلاثه على
الاقل من ضباط الحرس الثوري المختصين
بالدفاعات الجويه قتلوا داخل الاراضي
السوريه وعندما استهدفت اسرائيل في احد
ضربات ضربتين منها الدفاع الجوي الايراني
لن تكون الغار من اجل تدمير مستودعات بل
كانت غاره الاستردافها هؤلاء ونحن نعلم
عندما شاهدنا ايضا في محيط السيده زينب
عندما استهدف المبنى المبنى كان عائد
لضباط ايرانيين موجودين في تلك المنطقه
قتل ثلاثه
قد يكون من الاضبان ولكن لم يقولوا
للجنسيه السوريه
اتهم قائد الوصول خامس البحريه الامريكيه
ادميرال براد كوبر التهم ايران مباشره
بالوقوف وراء غالبيه الهجمات في المنطقه
وقال كوبا خلال مؤتمر البحريه فواشنطن ان
استخدام القدرات القتاليه خلال الهجمه
المتكرره في المنطقه تقوم به ايران مباشره
او من خلال ميليشتها في الشرق الاوسط
ان المخاطر المهدي
مقابلتها منذ شهرين مثلا كان هناك هجوم
بالمسيرات على سفينه تجاريه وفتحت فجوه في
جسم السفينه هذا الهجوم وصل الى الجسم
الداخلي للناقله وكان من الممكن ان يكون
الوضع ماسويه لكن من حسن الحظ ان لا
اصابات وقعت في صفوف البحاره لكن الهجوم
يعكس استخدام ايران المتكرر والمتزايد
للقدرات القتاليه حيث تقوم بذلك مباشره او
عن طريق الميليشيات التابعه لها في الشرق
الاوسط تجدر الاشاره الى ان هذه الق هل
تعطيها ايران بروسيا للقيام بهاجماتها على
اوكرانيا
هنا بالعوده مره اخرى الى ملف في عمليه
الطعن في باريس من العاصمه الفرنسيه
العربيه حسين قنيبر اهلا بك حسين واخر
التحديثات المتوفره اليك حول هذه العمليه
نعم احمد نحن من الاقتراب من المكان الذي
وقع فيه الاعتداء وسنحاول الدخول مره
جديده بعد دقائق من الان الشرطه ضربت طوقا
امنيا محكما حول محطه قطارات الشمال
جاردينار المنطقه التي ارتكب فيها المعتد
اعتدائه قام بتعني عده اشخاص بسلاح ابيض
تحديدا بسكين اصيب خمسه اشخاص من بين
الذين كانوا موجودين حوله بجراح طفيفه كما
اصيب احد عناصر الشرطه لدى تدخل قوه امنيه
للسيطره على المعتدي اصيبه احد عناصرها
بجراح طفيفه ايضا اطلق عناصر الامن النار
على المعتدي فاصيب بجراح خطيره في صدره
وحياته في خطر نقل الى المستشفى قبل قليل
من الان قبل دقائق قليله وصل الى حطت عقار
جنور وزير الداخليه شغال دافنان وايضا
قائد شرطه باريس
وكانت موجوده قبلهما في المكان عمده
الشرطه طلبت من المدنيين الابتعاد عن
منطقه وقوع الاعتداء وتقوم بالتحقيق في
ظروف هذا الاعتداء التي تبقى غامضه كما
تبقى غامضه دوافع المعتدي احمد هل هناك اي
معلومات اوليه حسين عنه هويه هذا المعتدي
بالنظر الى اصابته الخطره والى عدم التحقق
من ما اذا كان يحمل اوراقا ثبوتيه لم يذكر
اي شيء اقله حتى الان عن هويته ولا عن
دوافع هذا الاعتداء وطبيعه وقوعه ليس
بالامكان بعد تحديد ما اذا كان هذا
الاعتداء عملا ارهابيا ام انه عمل فردي او
انه نجم عن مشاجره او لم تسبقه مشاجره بل
ان المعتدبات الى طعم من كانوا حوله بسكين
كل ذلك يتضح من خلال تصريحات سيدلي بها
اما مسؤول رفيع المستوى في الشرطه او وزير
الداخليه شخصيا والذي وصل الى محطه نار او
قائد شرطه باريس كل ذلك سيصتضح بعد قليل
الحادث وقع قبل دقائق من الساعه السابعه
صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي في المحطه التي
تحمل المسافرين الى مناطق في الشمال
الفرنسي احمد وهي شرايين حركه النقل العام
ضمن المناطق والاحياء الواقعه في باريس
وايضا بين باريس ومناطق فرنسيه ومدن
فرنسيه اخرى خصوصا تلك التي تقع في شمال
البلاد حركه السير في باريس بسوره عامه
وفي محطه القطارات تحديدا هل عادت الى
طبيعتها حسين
في محطه القطارات تتعطلت حركه النقل العام
وفي جميع الخطوط الواقعه في مناطق مجاوره
لمحطه قطارات الشمال
تعطلت حركه مترو الانفاق وحركه القطارات
السريعه وكذلك حركه حافلات النقل العام
فيما عد ذلك في الاحياء الاخرى في باريس
بقيت الحركه شبه طبيعيه ولكن اتعطلت حركه
القطار حركه مترو الانفاق بضع دقائق عند
الخط رقم واحد في العاصمه الفرنسيه وهو
الذي ينقل ركبا في جوار قوس النصر وساحه
لكم كارد وصولا الى الباستيل وساحه الامه
هذا الخط عطلت الحركه عليه للاشتباه بامر
ما لكن الحركه قبل دقائق من الان وعادت
الى طبيعتها قبل دقائق من الان احمد الى
عينا معك على اي تفاصيل جديده شكرا لك من
فارس وانت معنا مراسل العربيه حسنا خبر
تحيه الحسين
نشاطره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
وفاته شابه الايرانيه في ظروف غامضه بعد
زياره الحرس الثوري
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افادت مصادر
موقع ايران تمشينال ان سقوط الشابه بهار
خورشيدي من نافذه منزلها ووفاتها لاحقا تم
خلال مداهمه قوات الامن للمنزل في محاوله
القبض عليها مصادر موقع ايران
قوات الامن خورشيد كان توزيعها واختها
لمنشورات كتب عليها
والحريه باحد احياء العاصمه لا حققهن ضباط
امن بلباس المدني داخل احد محال الخياطه
قبل ان تفرخ خورشيد منزلها الذي سقطت منها
فائدته اثناء مداهمه قوات الامنيه
ميثم الجبليش شقيقه بمن جبل رئيس الاذاعه
والتلفزيون الايراني انه ترك عائلته وغادر
لانه لم يعد يحتمل كذبا النظام الايراني
التي اسقطها الحرس الثوري في يناير 2020
ما ادى الى مقتل 276 راكبا بين ابن اخي
وقال ميثم جبلي في مقابله مع مجله طعم
الامريكيه انه عندما راى شقيقه بيمان جبلي
يكذب بشان الطائره الاوكرانيه نفذ صبره
مشيرا الى انه يعتقد ان لا شيء اصعب من
ترك العائله ولكنه لا يستطيع العيش وسط
اكاذبهم مؤكدا انه يتمتع الان بوضع لاجئ
بعد ما قدم طلب للوجوب
مشاهدينا من دبي ينضم الينا الصحفيه
المختص في الشارع الايراني مسعود الفتح
اهلا بك سيد مسعود معنا في هذه النشره كما
تبعنا حصيله ضحايا هذه الاحتجاجات تزداد
يوما بعد يوم دون وجود مؤشرات حقيقيه من
النظام على التراجع وكذلك حتى المحتاجين
لا يريد انهم يتراجعون والسؤال هنا من اين
يستمد هؤلاء المحتجون عزيمتهم في
الاستمرار
تحياتي لك هو للمشاه الكرام
بلا شكاره
قلنا هذا مرارا بان هذه الاحتجاجات مختلفه
تماما تختلف عن سابقاتها من الاحتجاجات
ولكن قد تفطر الاحتجاجات قد تخف
الاحتجاجات الا انها لن تتوقع في فرق بان
بين ان تخف الاحتجاجات او تتوقف لدى نرى
بين الحين والاخر مدن في ايران تنتفض مثلا
مدينه جاهدان عاصمه
بين الحين والاخر همم وايضا في العاصمه
طهران الحارات المعروفه في في العاصمه
والاحياء المعروف العاصمه نراها تغير
اسلوب الاحتجاج وتنتقل من الشارع مثلا الى
السطوح الى الى خلف النوافذ الى الشرفات
وبهذه الطريقه النظام في واقع الان همم
ينوع اساليب القمح والمحتجون ينوعون
اساليب المواجهه والتعبير عن احتجاجاتهم
للوضع الراهن القوه من اين يستمدونها
باعتقائدها القوه يشتمدونها من الوضع
الاجتماعي السيء الوضع السياسي اصعب
الظروف الاقتصاديه المتازمه كل هذه الامور
تعطي دفعه للمحتاجين ان ينزلوا الى
الشوارع والا احد يريد ان يعرف نفسه للخطر
وينزل الى الشارع ليحتاج فقط لانه يحتاج
لو لم تكن هناك اسباب موضوع المحتاجين هذه
الاسماء
هذه الازمه اصبحت مثل كره الثلج المتحده
تكبر يوما بعد اليوم
ومع ذلك يبدو ان النظام ليس قابلا للسقوط
حتى هذه اللحظه ما الذي ينقص هذا الحراك
يكون اكثر فاعليه وتاثيرا
قالت السقوط او البقاء هي مساله مرتبطه
بالظروف الموضوعيه الداخليه قد تكون
الاحتجاجات هي عباره عن محطات اا تتقدم
نحو مواجهه النظام اما ان يسقط واما ان
يغير تصرفاته اما ان يقبل بالتراجع وقبول
وقبول بعض على اقل تقدير كحد ادنى بعض
مطالب المحتجين او انه يواجه همم السقوط
مساله السقوط قد تكون في هذه الحاله مساله
وقت ايه وترتبط بالظروف الداخليه ترتبط
مدى اتساع الاحتجاجات ومدى تنظيمها ومدى
قياده هذه الاحتجاجات باعتقادي المساله لن
تكون الوضع في ايران لن يكون كما كان قبل
هذه الاحتجاجات التي بدات في صباح في 17
سبتمبر الماضي حاضر حضرتك
وبعد سبتمبر مختلف تماما هنا جيل جديد
يرفض الوضع الموجود يريد حياه مرتبطه
بالعالم يريد ان يكون ظن وجزء من هذه
القريه العالميه الصغيره التي ترتبط
ببعضها البعض من خلال الثوره المعلومات
الحديثه وهنا السؤال يعني حول ما اذا كان
عدم وجود قياده تؤطر هذه الاحتياجات حاليا
هل هو عامل قوه ام عامل اضعاف لها في
تقديرك
بالنسبه للداخل مساله
الاحتجاجات الافقيه التي لا يمكن للنظام
ان يكشف من يقودها اااه هي تعتبر نقطه قوه
الاحتجاجات لو كانت الاحتجاجات
قيادتها
عموديه في هذه الحاله كشف قادت الاحتجاجات
ومن يقومون بتنظيمها عمليه سهله للسلطات
الامنيه والقضاء على القيادات ولكن في
الحاله الافقيه وانتشار القيادات في مختلف
المدن وفي مختلفه الحارات ك- حاله مدينه
مثل مدينه طهران الكبرى باعتقاده هي تشكل
نقطه قوه للمحتاجين وتعطيهم قوه
للاستمراريه والابداع في اساليب الاحتجاج
نكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا لك من دبي كنت معنا
الصحفي المختص في شيء الايراني مسعود
الفقر شكرا لك استاذ مسعود
شكرا لك
دهنه المنظمه الدوليه لحقوق الانسان تعرض
مغني الراب الشهيره توماجي صالحي لما سمته
اشكالا قاسيه من التعذيب داخل السجون
الايرانيه منذ 22 من اكتوبر عام الماضي
وفي تغييره الله على تويتر اشاره منظمه
التي يقع مقرها في المملكه المتحده الى
منع المغني الايراني من الحصول على حقه في
العلاج الطبي مضيفا انه كان صوتا لمن لا
صوت لهم في ايران كما طالبه المنظمه
التضامن مع دوليا
انما سماه تسليح الاجراءات الجنائيه من
قبل النظام الايراني لمعاقبه المواطنين
على ممارسه حققهم الاساسيه مثل المشاركه
في التظاهرات او تنظيمها يرقى الى حد
القتل التي تقره دولته كما استشهد مالي في
تغريته بمطالبه مفاوض الامم لحقوق الانسان
قال شرطه مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه انها
تحقق في واقعه ضبط عينات يوراني ضئيله
كانت على مثل رحله قادمه من سلطنه عمان
الى مطار هيثرو وفقا لصحيفه ستان
البريطانيه فين الواقعه تعود الى يوم
التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر الماضي وكانت
في حقيبه موجهه الى شركه الايرانيه لديها
مقرات في المملكه المتحده واشارت قياده
شرطيه الى ان المواد التي تم اكتشافها لا
تشكل تهديده للجمهور ولم تسل التحقيقات
الى الان عن ارتباطها باي تهديد مباشر
يعتبر القوات الامن الايرانيه على
اللاجئين الافغان في الحدود التركيه
الايرانيه هو قامت بدربهم وحرقهم كما
التقطت لهم صورا وهم عراه
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
افغانستان اذا مشاهدينا تعيش اوضاعا صعبه
بسبب القرارات التي تتخذها قياده الطالبان
واخيرها حرمان نساء من الدراسه الجامعيه
ومنعهن من العامل مع منظمات غير الحكوميه
افغانستان بين اجد الحكومه في كابول وتشدد
القياده في قندهار يغرق شعبها يوما بعد
الاخر في الجهل والفقر كيف لا وقد قررت
قياده طالبان منع الفتيات والنساء من
الدراسه بجميع مستوياتها في تراجع عن
التزاماتها بحفظ حقوق المراه
هرموا السلطه في طالبان موزع بين كابول
عاصمه البلاد
وقندهار مسقط راس مؤسس الحركه الملا عمر
واغلب قادتها الحاليين هناك وهم هبه الله
اخوان زاد زعيم الحركه عبد الحكيم حقاني
قاضي القضاه الملا محمد حسن اخوند رئيس
الوزراء نور محمد ثابق وزير الحج والارشاد
حبيب الله اغا وزير التعليم العام نداء
محمد نديم وزير التعليم العالي
هذه الاسماء الموجوده في قندهار تقف وراء
القرارات الاخيره ضد المراه خاصه زعيم
الحركه الذي يحتفظ بالكلمه الاخيره في
جميع قرارات السياسه الوطنيه الرئيسيه
الامر الذي يثير حفيظه وجوه اخرى في حركه
طالبان تتبنى التوجه الاصلاحيه وترى ان
الدوده لا جدوى منه
اداره الحكومه والبلاد لا تصلح بالتشدد
والتطرف والشعب وضع اممله فينا وجعلنا نصب
اعينه نحن الافغان هزمنا ثلاثه
امبراطوريات اليس من العار علينا ان نمد
ايدينا الى امريكا لطلب المساعدات نحن امه
المجاهده ونطلب من الكفار الاكل هذا
يظهرون هناك افغان عديم كرامه
ومهما يكن من امر فان قرارات طالبان
الاخيره اعادت البلاد للمواجهه الداخليه
والمحتمله مع الخارج ما يعني ان مشوار
افغانستان ما يزال طويلا للوصول الى نقطه
الاستقرار
انسنا الناسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
نشاطها مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
كتاب الامير هاري يفوق التوقعات ويسجل
مبيعات قياسيه خلال ساعات من طرحه في
المكتبه
عمليه الطعن في محطه للقطارات شمال
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس والشرطه تعلن
تحييد المهاجم
مجموعه تقوم بتمشيط مدينه صول دار
الاستراتيجيه ولاحكام السيطره وتعلن وعدد
الاسرى اليوم
مصادر استخباراتيه تؤكد احباط اسرائيل
لمخطط في سوريا كلف ايران ملايين
الدولارات
شرطه مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه تحقق بطرد
مشبوه ملوث باليورانيوم كان بطريقه لشركات
ايرانيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في السودان تتواصلوا
اعمال ورشه تفكيك النظام الثلاثين من
يونيو ضمن مؤتمراتي خارطه طريق القضايا
الخمسه التي اقرتها القوه المدنيه الموقعه
لاتفاق الاطاري حيث يسعى الائتلاف السياسي
الى تجاوز المشاكل والاخطاء التي شافت
اعمال لجنه ولفت الرئيس المناوب للجنه
التفكيك محمد الفلكي سليمان الى محاوله
دمج لجنه التفكيك مع باقي اجهزه الدوله
في السودان ايضا مشاهدينا قطعت وزاره
التربيه والتعليم اضراب للجنه المعلمين
بدا قبل ايام بعد اعلانها عن اجازه للفصل
الدراسي الاول
في القطاعين العام والخاصر وتزامنه
الاجازه التي لم تكون موضوعه في التقويم
الدراسي مع اضراب المعلمين الذين يطالبوا
بزياده الصرف على قطاع التعليم وزياده
الحد الادنى للاجور
مدارس وخلت من ضجيج التلاميذ وحركتهم ساحه
هادئه وفصول مغلقه بعد ان رفع المعلمون
شعار تحسين الاجر مقابل العمل
اضراب كان متدرجا ومتدبدبا لكنه دخل الان
الى مرحله جديده بعد ان طلبت بعض المدارس
من تلاميذها عدم الحضور الى المدرسه بسبب
الاضراب
المطالبه بزياده الراتب مئه وخمسه عشر
دولارا كلها اسباب واعذار لم تجد طريقها
الى الحل
هم بيطالبوا
بالصرف على التعليم باعتبار النهائيه قضيه
بتم المجتمع بشكل عام انه لابد للدوله ان
تضع ميزانيه 20% من موازنتها للصرف على
التعليم
والمعلمين بيطالبه برده بزياده الحد
الادنى
69% من الحد الادنى
للازمه هنا بعد اخر
المتضررون هم تلاميذ المدارس الحكوميه اثر
خلاف مظل قائما بين المعلمين ووزاره
التربيه والتعليم بسبب ضعف المرتبات كارثه
تنذر بان يخسر التلاميذ عامهم الدراسي
ترسلون نجلاء ابنتها ترتيل الى المدرسه
يوميا دون فائده تذكر اذ اصبحت الام تؤدي
دور المدرسه في التعليم استياء كان واضحا
على اسر عديده يدرس ابنائهم في المدارس
الحكوميه نحن
الاضراب بتاع المعلمين ده فين الطالب يعني
العام الدراسي
في مدارس مدربه مدارس غير مطربه يعني حتى
في الحكومي ذاته
تداعيات استدعت ان تتدخل وزاره التربيه
والتعليم لتعلن عن تعديل التقويم الدراسي
بمنح اجازه تبدا في الحادي عشر من هذا
الشهر وتستمر ثلاثه اسابيع
معالجات يراها البعض تطويل الازمه وهروب
من الحل
فالدراسه في السودان باتت تتعطل للاضراب
والتظاهرات والخريف وبعض الامراض وايضا في
منح الاجازات لن يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم
يه سريه عثر عليها في مكتبه السابق تعود
الى فتره عمله كنائب للرئيس السابق اوباما
وعلى هامشي قمه الامريكيه الكنديه
المكسيكيه قال بايظ انه ابلغ بما تم
العثور عليه ولا يعرف ما تحتوي هذه
الوثائق وهذا فوائد
بوجودها في مكتبه مؤكد ان محامي سيتعاونون
بشكل كامل من خلال فحص الوثائق واعت ذلك
بعد ما اعلن محامين العثور على وثائق
السريه في مكتبه بمركز ابحث واشنطن
وتسليمها الى هيئه المحفوظات
تيتو مواعيد
السريه على محمل الجد لقد ابلغت بما تم
العثور عليه وفوجئت عندما علمت ان وثائقي
متعلقه بالحكومه نقلت الى ذلك المكتب لكني
لا اعرف ما تحتويه تلك الوثائق لقد سلمت
الصناديق الى الارشيف ونحن نتعاون بشكل
كامل وامنوا ان تنتهي مراجعه الوثائق
قريبا وسيكون هناك المزيد من التفاصيل في
ذلك الوقت
في هذا المبنى في الطابق السادس عثر على
وثائق التقريبا 10 صنفت بانها وثائق سريه
تابعه للرئيس بيضين عندما كان يشغل منصب
نائبا رئيس طبعا هذا سبب احراج كبير للبيت
الابيض لانه اتهم بالزواجيه المعايير
بالمقارنه مما حدث مع الرئيس ترامب الذي
حقق الاف بي اي في الوثائق التي وجدت في
مره لارجو لكن البعض يقول بانه لا مقارنه
اولا البيت الابيض اعرب عن تعاونه مع طبعا
مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي وقال بانه يريد ان
يعيد كل هذه الوثائق الى الارشيف الوطني
وان هذه الوثائق لا تحمل مثلا اسرار نوويه
او غيرها لكن بغض النظر رئيس مجلس النواب
كيف المقاس قال بان الامر مقلق للغايه
وهذا طبعا سيسبب احراج كبير للبيت الابيض
وقد يؤثر على مستقبل الرئيس السياسي
هذا هو حصلت العربيه على صور خاصه من امام
مكتب الرئيس الامريكي في مركزه للدراسات
حيث تم العثور على وثائق البيت الابيض
السريه
[موسيقى]
صوت الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي
على انشاء لجنه الفرعيه مختاره بشان ما
يسمى بتسليح الحكومه الفيدراليه ويرى خبره
وانا لجنه الفرعيه الجديده تستهدف تحقيقات
الجاريه في وزاره العدل ومكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي بشان الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
تشكيل المجلس النواب الامريكي لجنه قضائيه
فرعيه للتحقيق بما يسمى بتسليح الحكومه
الفيدراليه خطوه جديده نحو احتدام الصراع
بين الجمهوريين واداره ايضا فمهام اللجنه
الفرعيه ستشمل وفقه مراقبين مراجعه
التحقيقات مع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
والخوض في القضايا القانونيه التي تدور
حوله وسيكون لديها سلطه الاشراف على
التحقيقات الجنائيه الجاريه كما يمكنها
الوصول الى نفس المعلومات التي تطلع عليها
لجنه الاستخبارات
في الاشراف على الاداره هذا من واجباتنا
لقد تم اهمالها خلال العامين الماضي
سنجرى اشراف قويا للتاكد من ان اموال
دافعين الضرائب انفقت بشكل صحيح وللتخلص
من الهدر والاحتيال وسوء المعامله التي
رايناها في الحكومه من المجموعات الحكوميه
كما ستحقق اللجنه الفرعيه التي سيراسها
جيم جاردن المقرب من ترامب في الاتصالات
بين شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى واداره ايضا
للضغط على المحافظين على الانترنت
وتشكيل هذه اللجنه الفرعيه هي احدى هذه
الوعوده وواحده من اوائل المواجهات مع
الديمقراطيين خلال العامين المقبلين
يعتبرون ان تشكيلها لجنه الفرعيه احد
التنازلات التي قدمها رئيس المجلس كبنك
جمهورينا للفوز بمطرقه المجلس معتبرين ان
ذلك ليس من مصلحه الامريكيين ومؤكدين على
اشراكته
مختاره مع قياده من جانب الاغلبيه من
مصلحتنا التاكد من اننا نمثل دور الكونجرس
والشعب
الامريكيين ليس لديهم فرصه خلف الابواب
مغلقه لاضافه نظريات المؤامره
وفيما يتهم الجمهوريون الديمقراطيين بما
يسمى بتسليح الحكومه الفيدراليه
يردمقراطيون ان هذه اللجنه الفرعيه
الجديده هي السلاح نفسه حسين الطاوض
العربيه واشنطن
افاده ناشر مذكرات الامير البريطاني هاري
بان مذكراته التي تحمل عنوان سبير او
الاحتياطي اصبحت اسرع كتاب في بريطانيا
وذلك بعد بيع 400 الف نسخه حتى الان في
صوره مطبوعه ورقيه واكتونيه وصوتيه حيث
كشف العضو المنتدى بدار النشر لاعرفيا له
في بيان ان الداره كانت تتوقع ان يحقق
الكتاب رواجا كبيرا لكنه تجاوز حتى اكثر
توقعاتنا تفاؤنا مضيفا موضوعات الوحيده
التي بعد اكثر في يومها الاول هي تلك التي
كانت التي كانت بطلها هاري بوتر
اخيرا كتاب سيره الامير هاري على رفوف
المكتبات والمتاجر صار في متناول محبي
الامير وكاريه على السواق لتصفح الصفحات
ال 416 وما تحتويه من فيض من التفاصيل
المثيره عن حياته وعن الخلافه داخل عائلته
من كشفه عن مشاجره مع اخيه وليام وصولا
الى اعترافه بقتل 25 مقاتلا في طالبان
وكلامه عن طاعه المخدرات كلها امور اثارت
ردود فعل عديده وستترك بلا شك اثرا على
مبيعات الكتاب وشعبيه الامير
اشتريت الكتاب لانني اريد ان اكون جزءا من
التاريخ ولمعرفتي ما جرى في القصر خصوصا
الامور التي لم نسمع عنها من قبل وكيف
تصرفت الصحافه مع هاري
لترويج كتابه ومزعم مثيره طالت افراد
العائله الملكيه صدمت متابع الامير
وعائلته من جهه ومؤيد العائله المالكه من
جهه اخرى وان كانت الغالبيه ترى ضروره
ابقاء اسرار العائله الملكيه ومشاكل
اعضائها حديثه القصر لن اقتني الكتاب
لاننا قضينا وقتا كافيا للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع وحصل على ما يكفي من الدعايه ولا
اظن ان من المنطقي شراء الكتاب
قد لا اشتري الكتاب وليس لدي شيء ضد
الكتاب اتعاطف مع الامير لكن لا اظن انه
يستحق اضاعه وقتي لقراءته
سيجني الامير هاري الملايين من الجنيهات
من مبيعات الكتاب وسيخص جزء منها لمنظمه
خيريه اسسها لمساعده الاطفال المصابين
بفيروس نقص المناعه في افريقيا
يحتلوا كتابه مذكرات الامير هاري المرتبه
الاولى في قوائم مبيعات الكتب على موقع
امازون ويتوقعوا ان يحضر كتابه باقبال
كبير في المكتبات بعد حمله التسويقيه منذ
الاعلامي عن نشر سيرته الذاتيه
كعادتها التزمت العائله الملكيه السمطه
ولم تعلق على مزاعم الكتاب تركه الكلام
لهاري ولقراء ليحكموا على تداعيات اصداره
على المدى الطويل مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
الناصري
شكرا احمد اهلا بكم في تحديث ارقام جلسه
هذا اليوم حيث
الاسواق في الخليج حاليا مستقره نوعا ما
بالرغم من بدايه على بعض الارتفاعات
الطفيفه التي تبددت خلال منتصف جلسه هذا
اليوم استقرار في السوق السعودي في دبي
تراجع طفيف في ابو ظبي ارتفاع طفيف في
الكويت الاول وايضا الدوحه مستقره ماذا عن
الاسهم التي نراقبها هذا اليوم لخريف طبعا
همم فازت بعقد ب 90 مليون ريال تقريبا
لتشغيل شبكات المياه في المدينه المنوره
السهم على تراجع معادن في ضوء على هامش
مؤتمر التعدين الدولي المقام في الرياض
حاليا والذي انطلقت اعماله صباح هذا اليوم
همم وقعت العديد من الشركات لانشاء شركات
همم في السعوديه همم مع شركات اجنبيه على
راسها بارك بارك
وطبعا للتنقيب والاستكشاف عن همم معادن
وايضا صندوق مع صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
مشروع مشترك وشركه للاستثمار في الاصول
التعدينيه ولكن دوليا خارج المملكه الحفر
العربيه ترتفع بثلاثه في المئه بعد فوزها
بعقد مع ارامكو لتقديم وتشغيل منصه حفر
بحريه لمده خمس سنوات 650 مليون ريال بوبا
العربيه طبعا الكسور من الاسهم في زياده
راس المال الاخيره همم
الايرادات من بيعه تلك الكسور
تعاد الى حسابات المساهمين يوم غدا يوم
غدا مؤشر سوق دبي على استقرار نظره سريعه
على الاسهم الاكثر نشاطا هناك امراه تراجع
بواحد في المئه بعد اصداره سندات
بملياردرهام همم اعمار العقاريه بعض
الارتفاع سالك قفزه قويه فيها في ابو ظبي
ايش سي على بعض التراجع ابو ظبي للموانئ
تخالف الاتجاه العام للاسهم لاكثر نشاطا
وترتفع بواحد ونصف النق المئويه اما في
السوق الكويتيه التي شهدت تداولات همم
قويه الامس الكويت الاول تداول عليه اكثر
من 40 مليون دينار وشاهدنا مكاسب قويه على
بيتك باكثر من اثنين في المئه بيتك يواصل
المكاسب اليوم ولكن بنصف النقطه المئويه
وطني الذي لم يشارك في ارتفاعاته يوم امس
ما زال على استقرار عند ال 1980 همم فلس
واا في اسواق النفط سعر برنت الان يتجاوز
الثمانين دولار يخفف الخسائر التي كان قد
تعرض لها صباح هذا اليوم في ظل صدور ليله
الامس بعض البيانات عن المخزونات
الامريكيه التي كان وقعها سلبيا على اسعار
النفط التي لا تتزال او لا تزال تترجع همم
حول مستويات الثمانين دولار للبرميل في ظل
التخوف من ان التباطؤ الاقتصادي العالمي
سيضر بالطلب على النفط هذه كانت وقفتنا مع
الاسواق مشاهدينا نعود من جديده لست
جهاتنا في الرياض مع كاحمد
شكرا لك ناصر مشاهدينا اكثر من تسعه الاف
عنصر من الجيش والشرطه العراقيه يعملون
على تامين الحمايه الجماهير والوفود
المشاركه في بطوله الخليج لكره القدم
نسختها الخامسه والعشرين في البصره تابعه
على مدار 24 ساعه يوميا يعمل اكثر من تسعه
الاف عنصر من الجيش والشرطه في مدينه
البصره لتامين الحمايه للملاعب والطرق
والمشجعين ومحل اقامه الفرق المشاركه في
بطوله كاس الخليج بنسختها الخامسه
والعشرين
على نجاح الخطبه وسير الحركه بصوره صحيحه
الوفود تروح من المذهب من ذهاب الى الملعب
والذهاب الى الفنادق خاصه للمنتخبات
الثلاثه جدا ليش لانه نعرف اوقاتها ونعرف
تحركاتها وانهيلها الجو الملائم من الاصل
والرجاحهم وصولهم الى الملعب
وافقه اخر الارقام الرسميه فان اكثر من
160 الف مشجعا من دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وصلوا الى البصره برا وجوابحرا
بالامانه قعد احس اني انا بين اهلي والله
ما احس اني خرجت من الحدود
واحلى ما في البطوله هي اللي هي جمعت هذه
الناس
مرتاح والامور مستقره وفي رجال امن الحمد
لله مكثفين وما شفنا منهم الا كل كلمه يا
هلا يا مرحبا
ومشكورين والله
الكويتيون شكل النسبه الاكبر من اعداد
المواطنين الخليجيين الذين يدخلون الاراضي
العراقيه يوميا لمتابعه مباريات البطوله
الكرويه قياده عمليات البصره اكدت ان
اهالي المدينه ساهموا في انجاح الخطه
الامنيه الخاصه بتامين الحمايه لخليجي
خمسه وعشرين في هذه المدينه من مدينه
البصره منتظر الرشيد العربيه
بعد ثلاث سنوات تقريبا
الى اكثر من 20 سيناريو ابهر جميعها
بالمحصله خسائر بالغه في العديد والعتاد
لطرفيعه
معركه دون رابح ما خساره وزنه على الجهتين
هذا ما اظهرته سيناريوهاتن متعدده تحاكي
غزوه صينيا لتايوانه الجزيره التي تتمتع
بحكم ذاتي وتطالب الصين باستعادتها بالقوه
اللازمه الامر 24 سيناري واجرهم مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في واشنطن
استبعد جميعها خروج الصين منتصره من هكذا
حربه بل دفعها اثمانا هائله وبحسب
المحاكاه الحرب ستترك البحريه الصينيه في
حاله من الفوضى وتحطم جوهر قوتها البريه
والبحريه وستفقد الصين 255 طائره مقاتله
238 سفينه كبيره وفقا تقرير
خسارتها تمتد لقواتها مع توقعات بمقتل
حوالي 10,000 من جنودها واسرع عشرات
الالاف وفي خانه المدافعين عن تايوان قفوا
كل من الولايات المتحده واليابان البلدان
سيخسران عشرات السفن الحربيه ومئات
الطائرات المقاتله و خسائر بشريه بالالاف
فمظم السيناريوهات تتوقع ان تفقد البحريه
الامريكيه حاملتي طائرات وما بين عشره الى
20 سفينه مقاتله كبيره فيما تقول توقعات
ان نحو ثلاثه الاف ومئتا جنديا امريكيه
سيلقون مصرعهم خلال ثلاثه اسابيع من
القتال اي نحو نصف ما خسرته في عقدين من
القتال في العراق وافغانستان
اليابان ايضا خسائرها ليست بقليله وفق
المحاكاه اكثر من 100 طائره مقاتله و 26
سفينه حربيه حاله شلل ستعانيها البلدان
الثلاثه في حال حدوث الغزو واسع النطاق
للجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها 24 مليون نسمه
لكنه مستبعده وفقا خبراء
رغم قيامها بعمليات توغل منتظمه في المياه
والمجال الجوي قرب طيوان الا ان بكين لن
تخاطر بهكذا مناوره معدومه النتائج وتضر
اقتصادها بشكل هائل
تدريبات الشهر المقبل تدريباته تشمل
الردعه الموسعه والتحرك لمواجهه التحيه
النوويه لكوريا
قررت النيابه العامه المصريه حبسه ثلاثه
اشخاص في مصر في محاولتهم سرقه تمثال
رمسيس الثاني والذي يزن 10 اطنان وموجود
في منطقه المحجر الجنوبي بمحافظه اسوان
جنوبيه مصر واوضحت النيابه العامه في
بيانها انها تلقت بلاغ من الشرطه بضبط
ثلاثه اشخاص وبحوزتهم ادوات حفر يدويه
ومعدات ثقيله ورافعه حاله قيامه بمحاوله
رفع تمثال الملك رمسيس الثاني وتنقيبهم عن
الاثار في المنطقه
في نهايه النشره المشاهدين ان نذكر بابراز
العناوين
عمليه طعن في محطه القطارات شمال العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس والشرطه تعلن تحييد
المهاجم
مجموعه تقوم بتمشيط مدينه الاستراتيجيه
وليحكام السيطره وتعلن وعدل الاسرى اليوم
مصادر استخباراتيات تؤكد احباط اسرائيل
لمخطه في سوريا كلف ايران ملايين
الدولارات
شرطه مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه تحقق في
طرد مشبوه ملوث باليورانيوم كان في طريقه
لشركات ايرانيه
[موسيقى]